ein jahr ist es jetzt her dass die 15
jährige rebecca aus berlin verschwand
spurlos
wir wissen nicht einmal ob sie lebt oder
ob sie tot ist die polizei geht aber von
einem schweren verbrechen aus und wir
wollen herausfinden warum diese suche
eigentlich bis heute ohne ergebnis
geblieben ist welche hinweisen weiter
nachgegangen wird und welche chancen die
ermittler sehen dass sich dieser fall
doch noch lösen lässt genau ein jahr
nach beckers verschwinden also jetzt im
studio der ermittelnde staatsanwalt
martin klage herzlich willkommen
ja ein jahr nach beckers verschwinden
haben sie hoffnung dass sie noch lebend
gefunden werden kann
nein also wir haben keine hoffnung mehr
wir hatten schon relativ frühzeitig nur
noch sehr wenig hoffnung und die
weiteren ermittlungen haben leider da
nichts
positiveres erbracht wir meinen
weiterhin dass sie dieses haus des
schwagers nicht lebend verlassen hat
warum sind sie eigentlich so sicher dass
sie das haus nicht leben zu lassen hat
das haben die ermittlungen ergeben wir
haben alle alternativ szenarien geprüft
und die ermittelnde mordkommission hat
das auch untersucht intensiv untersucht
aber es hat letztlich nur dazu geführt
dass wir sagen können so kann es nicht
gewesen sein sowohl ein freiwilliges
verlassen der häuslichkeit als auch eine
entführung durch dritte beispielsweise
konnte aufschließen
ihr rebeccas schwager florian geht ja
immer noch als verdächtiger wie lange
kann eigentlich ermittelt werden die
ermittlungen dauern an bis sie
abgeschlossen sind
das ist dann der fall wenn es keine
vernünftigen akuten
ermittlungsmöglichkeiten und
erfolgversprechenden
ermittlungsmöglichkeiten mehr gibt hier
ist es so dass wir durchaus noch
hinweisen und spuren nachgehen und die
ermittlungen noch nicht am ende sind so
dass hier im moment noch keine
einstellung des ermittlungsverfahrens
anlegt wie können wir das eigentlich
ertragen dass er sich in ihren augen
sehr verdächtig benommen hat aber sie
ihm da nichts nachweisen können na das
ist natürlich in solchen kapital fällen
kapitaldelikten besonders belastend aber
das sind sachen die staatsanwältinnen
und staatsanwälte häufiger haben dass
sie beschuldigt haben von denen sie
schon der meinung sind dass sie eine tat
begangen habe
er ist aber nicht nachweisen können wir
müssen es ihnen ja mit rechtsstaatlichen
mitteln nachweisen und das ist hier
bislang nicht der fall wir haben hier im
moment keinen dringenden tatverdacht
weil wir auch gar nicht genau sagen
können was in diesem haus genau passiert
ist insofern müssen wir damit im moment
leben aber wir hoffen natürlich dass wir
es noch aufklären können warum sind sie
sich ziemlich sicher sagen sie können
nämlich nachweisen aber warum sind sie
sich ziemlich sicher
wir sind uns sicher allein schon
deswegen weil er sich in widersprüche
verstrickt hatte hat als zeuge angaben
gemacht die die weiteren ermittlungen in
teilen wieder legen konnten
außerdem haben die ermittlungen ergeben
dass weitere alternativen wie ich eben
von sagte sehr unwahrscheinlich sind
er war allein mit rebecca vor ihrem
verschwinden im haus sodass wir fest
davon ausgehen dass er ebenfalls mit dem
verschwinden für uns auch mit dem tod zu
tun hat in welcher form das wissen wir
nicht ganz genau wenn sie ihm
konfrontiert haben damit dass einige
aussagen die stimmen werden reagiert ja
ihr habt das zunächst nicht erklären
können hat dann dazu nichts gesagt
später soll er seiner familie gegenüber
eine erklärung gefunden haben zb eine
erklärung dafür dass er als ja
eigentlich sagte er habe geschlafen dann
doch wir nachweisen konnten dass sein
fahrzeug auf der autobahn aufgenommen
werden konnte er sei wohl auf dem weg
nach polen gewesen um dort irgendetwas
zu kaufen möglicherweise drogen das
wurde uns dann später von der familie
berichtet das alles hat hat er dann so
angegeben aber wie gesagt das sind alles
angaben die uns letztlich nicht
überzeugen konnten
es hat ja eine wahnsinnig weit große
suche gegeben nach rebecca ist wurden
die wälder durch kemp spürhunde
eingesetzt
sie sind 1000 von hinweisen nachgegangen
haben sie das gefühl dass sie jetzt
alles getan haben um rebecca zu finden
den fall zu lösen na ja wir haben
zumindest weitgehend das getan was wir
bisher tun konnten alles noch nicht denn
wir haben sie noch nicht gefunden und
wir haben auch gehören auch noch nicht
auf sonst müsste ich das verfahren ja
bei ernstzunehmenden hinweisen sind wir
auch durchaus willens und bereit dann
wieder maßnahmen zu ergreifen
im moment werden wir spuren auswerten
hinweise aus und versuchen den fall auf
diese weise zu lösen aber ergebnis
leider offen sind das hinweise die sie
vor monaten bekommen aber da gibt es
auch immer wieder neue hinweise
es gibt neue hinweise wobei man schon
sagen muss dass die hinweise doch immer
weniger und auch in ihrer qualität eher
schwächer werden also wir bekommen dann
auch viele mutmaßungen und anregungen
wie jedoch ermittelt werden könnte aber
sie können gewiss sein dass die
mordkommission das zumeist alles schon
getan hat auch wenn es gut gemeint sind
bringen uns solche hinweise häufig nicht
weiter es wurde ja mit zwei
verschiedenen fotos gefahndet nachdem
becker einen bearbeiteten und einem
natürlichen warum sucht man mit so
versteht unterschiedlichen bildern
na ja sie hat sich eben auch im laufe
ihres jahren ihres jungen jugendlichen
leben verändert gerade das bearbeitete
bild stand ja in der kritik warum man
das nun genommen hat ja im nachhinein
kann man immer sagen hätte man
vielleicht ein anderes nehmen sollen
wobei man sagen muss dass gerade dieses
bild was so häufig in den medien gezeigt
wurde
doch ihrem aussehen wie ich finde gar
nicht so fern liegt denn so sah sie
tatsächlich in der letzten zeit aus aber
auch die anderen bilder ja man kann sich
immer fragen hätte man vielleicht andere
bilder nehmen können aber ich meine dies
waren schon durchaus gute bilder
entspricht dieses bild was wir hier
hinter und 10 entspricht das dem bild
wie sie natürlich aussah das ist ja
nicht das bekannteste peterson erkennt
na ja also das ist schon bearbeitet das
sieht man schon dass sie da natürlich
besonders aussehen wollte auf diesem
bild besonders hübsch aussehen wollte
wir haben aber zum beispiel ein video ja
jetzt neu noch mal gesehen eine einige
tage bevor die ihrem verschwinden wie
ich gehört habe
da sieht sie zumindest ähnlich aus nicht
ganz so aber ähnlich insofern meine ich
ist das bild jetzt ja wie gesagt man
hätte auch ein anderes nehmen können
aber so ganz verfehlt das ist nicht das
zu leben
worauf hoffen sie jetzt auch die leute
gehen jetzt nach hinweisen nach
was muss sozusagen passieren dass das
dass sie da jetzt weiterkommen warten
sie noch auf einen entscheidenden
hinweis das was braucht ja das wäre
natürlich schön und wir werden natürlich
froh in anführungsstrichen wenn wir sie
finden würden natürlich am glücklichsten
wenn wir sie leben finden würden aber
das können wir nach den ermittlungen aus
weitgehend ausschließen natürlich kann
man sich nie hundertprozentig sicher
sein aber da sprechen alle ermittlungen
dagegen und so schlimm es klingt aber
wir werden auch schon in den
ermittlungen weiter wenn wir ihre leiche
finden würden aber auch das ist ja
bislang noch nicht gelungen trotz
umfangreicher suchmaßnahmen danke der
klage also hier auch nochmal ein
dringender aufruf appell an alle die uns
jetzt zuschauen wenn man da noch
irgendwas weiß sicher irgendwas darin
hat dann sind sie immer noch für alle
hinweise dankbar und der fall wird
weiter bearbeitet danke sehr dass sie
heute bei uns war mutig scheint jetzt
unseren kollege matthias becker der ist
nämlich live von dem haus in dem rebecca
vor einem jahr übernachtet hat dem haus
ihrer schwester und ihrem schwager über
den wir gerade schon gesprochen haben
was vermutlich die letzte nacht ihres
lebens für halo matthias hallo matthias
werden gerade darüber gesprochen der
schwager von rebecca geht ihr immer noch
als verdächtig wie ist der aktuelle
stand genau wir schalten jetzt weil wir
ein kleines oli mit dem ton haben wir
hoffen dass wir gleich mal zurück
schalten können zu unserem kollegen
schalten wir erst zu deutschlands
bekanntestem profiler axel petermann
halle petermann
hallo ich grüße sie herr peter wenn sie
das so hören wie groß schätzen sie die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist eher becker noch
gefunden wird
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass rebecca
gefunden wird die dürfte natürlich immer
gegeben seien es fragt sich nur wie
findet man sie lebt wie noch oder ist
sie bedauerlicherweise tod und das ist
natürlich eine mutmaßung oder eine
befürchtung
jedoch wäre realistisch leider sein
könnte oder sein dürfte er steht uns ja
jetzt seit einem jahr was macht diesen
fall für sie so besonders
im prinzip ist es gar ein klassischer
vermisstenfall jeden tag verschwinden 2
300 menschen wäre sehr viele kern ja
immer wieder zurück natürlich auch
kinder und jugendliche also vom vom
verschwinden her erst einmal gar nichts
ungewöhnliches aber natürlich ist dieser
fall sehr sehr früh in den medien neben
haid sehr aufwändig berichtet worden und
die eltern selbst haben ja auch sehr
viel unternommen um rebecca zu finden
viele viele suchmaßnahmen gestartet also
das ist schon eine heraus
einzigartigkeit würde ich bald sagen
und natürlich die ermittler haben sich
auch erst noch festgelegt dass sie doch
meinte rebecca sei tot
eine andere erklärung werde es wohl
nicht geben und verantwortlich für ihren
tod dürfte ein schwager der ihr schwager
sein
für wie wahrscheinlich halten sie das
dass der schwager damit zu tun hat ich
werde immer von von dem ausgehen was der
alltag und zeigt gewalt in der familie
und angehörigen ist doch sehr stark
verbreitet und deswegen würde ich wenn
ich einen solchen fall zu bearbeiten
hätte auch erst einmal diesen ansatz
wählen um mich zu fragen was ist denn in
der nacht vor rebeccas verschwinden in
dem hause geschehen was hat sich da
zugetragen
und da haben wir eben gerade gehört ist
man offensichtlich sehr sehr
gewissenhaft vorgegangen hat viele
finalen viele versionen geprüft sich
überlegt conti rebecca vielleicht doch
freiwillig das haus verlassen haben aber
das ist ja negativ beschieden worden
also ich denke man sollte schon dort
beginnen wo jemand der verschwundenes
zuletzt gewesen ist muss das letzte
lebenszeichen von ihm gibt tschuldigung
was ist denn ihre these zu dem fall
naja die umstände sprechen wohl eher
dafür dass rebecca nicht mehr lebt man
muss sich jetzt fragen wie sie zu tode
gekommen muss es ein verbrechen sein
kann es auch ein unfall gewesen sein und
sie daraufhin dann versteckt wurde
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie sich
irgendwie jemanden zugewandt hat dort
seit und remscheid jetzt morgen einem
jahr dort lebt ist doch wohl eher
unwahrscheinlich möchte ich wohl sagen
und von daher gesehen muss man wohl von
einem verbrechen aus gehen
ganz herzlichen dank für ihre
einschätzung und damit gehe ich noch
einmal zurück zu kollege matthias becker
matthias ganz mich jetzt hören ich hörte
ich einwandfrei wirst du mich ja jetzt
richtig auch du stehst vor dem haus in
dem rebecca zuletzt gesehen wurde
mutmaßlich ihre letzte nacht verbracht
hat ihr schwager steht immer noch unter
verdacht wie ist der aktuelle standort
bislang sind heute über 2.300 hinweise
bei der mordkommission eingegangen aber
leider gottes ist keine heiße spur
darunter und auch leider kein
anzunehmender hinweis mehr
und wie es auch mit dem staatsanwalt
sagte es ist immer weniger was reinkommt
an information und deswegen jetzt
nochmal der appellen nochmal aufruf zu
allen zeugen- und anzunehmen den
hinweisgebern bei dir noch wie jemand
irgendwas gesehen hat möge er sich doch
beim lka berlin melden
jetzt ist ein video aufgetaucht dass
rebecca tanzend auf der musikplattform
tik tok zeigt der staatsanwalt das eben
schon angesprochen
relevant ist dieses video einig für die
neuen ermittlungen ich habe heute mit
ermittler gesprochen zu diesem video
dieses video ist relativ aktuell
der vorteil ist ist zeigt rebecca
so wie sie auch zu lebzeiten war als sie
noch bei der familie wohnte der nachteil
ist
es hat keinerlei fahndungs anhalte mehr
dieses video und es führt den
ermittlungen zum auffinden von rebecca
oder zum aufhellen was in der nacht oder
an dem morgen passiert ist leider die
ermittler kein stück weiter
du bist ja gerade vor dem haus des
schwagers und der schwester von rebecca
der schwager haben wir eben gehört steht
weiter unter verdacht der lebt jetzt
aber da eigentlich weiter wie bisher
oder ja wir haben uns auch heute hier
gewundert selbst der twingo oder
pinkfarbene twingo steht noch vor der
tür
hier ist alles so wie vor einem jahr so
wie es vor einem jahr auch gesehen habe
die hat sich eigentlich nichts verändert
und gibt es da im ort oder bei den
nachbarn gibt es da frust wenn man dich
jetzt da sieht die sagen lasst sie lasst
die leute jetzt endlich in ruhe
wir haben ja früher stimmen gehört die
diesen schwager auch sehr stark in
schutz genommen haben gesagt haben die
familie ist da genug gestraft ja die
nachbarn des historischen zwiegespalten
das verhältnis was sie haben zwischen
den medien und dem was passiert ist ich
glaube alle nachbarn wollen eigentlich
auch wissen was jetzt mit dem kind
passiert ist und alle wollen das kind
eigentlich auch wieder finden und
deswegen haben wir hier so eine
situation dass wir ertragen und geduldet
werden weil es geht halt um die 15
jährige schülerin genau das schicksal
der 15 jährigen rebecca aus berlin das
uns alle nicht los dass das bild
erinnern wir uns hier noch einmal der
eindringliche appell wirklich von allen
seiten mit weiteren hinweisen zu rebecca
damit dieser fall endlich gelöst